in many Shonen anime we see the journey
of a young and boastful character
learning how to control their abilities
and fighting off evils and injustice in
the world however alongside this stable
main character we often see a wise old
mentor character too beside being old
and gray these old men are anything but
fragile and weak they're some of the
toughest and strongest characters in
their universe so in this list we're
counting down the top 10 old badasses
from anime let's get to it
[Music]
we start off this list with none other
than Makarov from fairy tale the
loveable guild master of fairy tale has
to be powerful in order to be respected
and at times feared by his fellow guild
members
Makarovs definitely powerful being one
of the ten wizard saying he's also
capable of creating his own spells such
as fairy law a spell that's known to
eliminate anyone in every one that the
user sees as a danger to the caster and
his allies Makarovs also a master of a
multitude of magics ranging from his
giant magic to fairy magic and others
including wind and fire magic
this shows how versatile and fluent he
is in learning all sorts of abilities in
the magical world he resides in
[Music]
next to number 9 we have Walter from
Helsing ultimates in his youth
Walter was not only known to storm
occupied areas in Poland during the
Second World War but also helping to put
a stop to the creation of vampire armies
however Walters youth wasn't the only
period in his life which he was present
in all sorts of monumental events after
honing his skills for years Walter
earned the nickname
angel of death for the ways he could
kill someone even in his 60s he could
still rip through loads of vampires as
if he was a twenty-something Walter
despite taking up the role of a butler
later in life was still capable of
taking out hordes of the undead and did
so without even making it look like he
was struggling not to go for a more
demure
coming in at number seven is sarutobi
from Naruto this is the Third Hokage of
the Naruto series he was made to be the
Hokage by the second one at an early age
and despite his powers and abilities
deteriorating greatly with his age
the old man was still able to hold off
numerous powerful enemies with little to
no help at all sarutobi is ninjutsu is
immensely powerful as well having been
seen using all five basic nature
transformations as well as creating
several techniques on his own now when
facing new techniques he's able to
understand and break them down to the
point of mastering or creating a better
version for himself so Toby's truly
worthy of the title of Hokage and from
his mere feats and skills alone it's
clear that anyone who challenges him
must be stupidly brave or bravely stupid
or she Dani Sato from Arjun is here at
number 6
like all Arjun satyrs immortal he won't
die under any circumstances whatsoever
such as being crushed decapitated or
even malnourished who've not only the
abilities of an Aegean
esatto also has extensive military
training having served in an elite
operation for the US Marine corpse
during the Vietnam War he's also a
master manipulator
having tricked and allowed Kaine a guy
to trust him before showing his true
intentions
he's a man who separates his emotions
from his work a trait that helps him
perform ruthless crimes in the
underworld such as someone you don't
want to be on the bad side of and
someone who you shouldn't trust under
any circumstance as you can never be
sure of what his true motives really are
yeah Scarlett Connie
sparking tom is known most of the time
to be humorous anime there are times
when it brings us to the edge of our
seats with Hostin playing the role of
the main antagonist in the Yoshiwara in
flames ugh it was clear that his older
character wasn't gonna be as
light-hearted and funny as the usual
Bunch
rather hosan was described as a
bloodthirsty tyrant who ruled with an
iron fist even going so far as to show
him cutting the tendons of he Noah's
feet to make sure she couldn't run away
one of his many examples of his cruelty
his personality wasn't the only thing to
be feared though as wholesome produced a
multitude of superhuman traits such as
speed strength and durability a
dangerous man with dangerous morals
making for a thrilling arc in the
Gintama series
next is King Bradley from Full Metal
Alchemist not only is Bradley the
original Fuhrer of a mistress but the
final and one of the strongest
homunculus created by Father he has an
inhumane skill in swordsmanship at
hand-to-hand combat
now Bradley's a master of manipulation
putting on a front of being a wise old
gentleman while under the surface
he's an anger fueled man wanting nothing
more than to make father's wishes come
true by the other homunculus Bradley is
known to have inhumane speed durability
stamina and his ultimate eye this grants
him extrasensory vision and precognition
to events making him quite the hard foe
in a battle because he's not only hard
to strike but it's hard to get an upper
hand against him too
[Music]
I saw a cycling tour nothing
Mooji
coming in at number three is Yamamoto
from Bleach
don't let how this old man looks for you
he's very experienced and is a master
swordsman with incredible spiritual
power endurance durability and strength
his weapon is one of the oldest and most
powerful zanpakuto in Soul Society
this combined with Yamamoto spiritual
pressure creates a fiery orator appear
around him due to both having a similar
elemental affinity to fire Yamamoto
himself claimed that releasing his
bankai and his prolonged use could end
up destroying everything from his
opponent himself and soul society itself
talk about being an overpowered old man
huh
machine week I'm annoyed natella like
many other older gentlemen on this list
was abnormally gifted in his youth
having a great skill set in mastering
men to be in place as the head of the
exam board and the 12th chairman of the
hunter Association even with a teasing
and calm personality angering this old
man would be the greatest mistake anyone
could make he claimed the title of the
most powerful menus of 50 years prior to
the series he has control over at least
three nen categories who came firstly
his natural category enhancement which
in conjunction with his astounding
martial arts skills and strong body make
him a dreadful Malay fighter then a
mission which activates his strongest
attack and finally he employs
manipulation to make the men statue
mimic his movements it's no wonder why
this old man has placed so highly on our
list with the skills he possesses and
finally at number one we have none other
than white beard from one piece Edward
Newgate more commonly known as white
beard was at one point known as the
strongest man in the world and the one
who came the closest to one piece he was
known to be one of the few men in the
world who could ever match the Lake
Pirate King
Goldie Roger in a fight white beard 8
the quake grapefruit a paramecia type
devil fruit that made him a quake man
and which was considered the strongest
devil fruit within the paramecia class
according to San Goku
white beard had the power to destroy the
world truly someone you wouldn't want to
upset seeing as even death had a hard
time taking this old man down
[Music]
and with that we finish off our list of
all badasses you clearly don't want to
challenge but which all fighting geezer
is your favorite let us know in the
comments below thank you so much for
watching this video
be sure to leave a like subscribe for
more great anime content until next time
remember that with age always comes more
than mere wisdom
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]